yo what's happening y'all it's Mario
check me out right here on the bootleg
cab podcast you don't want to miss this
one
bootleg cat podcast bootleg cab show
special guests in here yeah I got Mario
yeah yeah Mario
yeah podcast blue light cap show special
guest my man come on bro you've been
down this [__] a long time man even
though you've been doing this [__] too
long you already know man how you doing
though man I'm so good bro I'm so
blessed man I'm so I'm just I'm lit
right now I'm excited man it's a lot
going on team winning we we moving yeah
I mean I've been loving working hard
it's the output of music thank you
you've been putting out music
consistently but now Quality Music which
you've always done throughout your
career but I just you know I feel like
you just been on your [__] Bro the last
couple years like no definitely it's
definitely been like a you know a
building brick Brick by Brick process
you know to a bigger picture that we
have in terms of just like re
resurfacing a brand fully you know of
Mario do you kind of look at like what
happened because I feel like when I
think of the pandemic I think of verses
and when I think of verses I think of a
few things I think a Jadakiss showing
people that you really got to be able to
rap right and then I think about you
showing people
no you got to be able to sing if you can
hang with me like for real soon like you
you smoke the Marion in that verses
respectfully because Mario's a legend
but you smoked them obviously you gotta
hear records but you also were like
there's no Antics involved like I'm just
gonna say raw bro it's raw you know what
I'm saying the same way I came in the
game yeah I'm saying the same one I'm
just refined you know I'm saying the
same young dude y'all fell in love with
singing Just a Friend and break my hand
you like yo why why is this the 106 and
Park kid you know what I'm saying it's
just refined man and I think versus just
really gave me a platform to remind
people yeah what that frequency is you
you look at that moment as kind of like
because you were of course at the time
you were still doing your thing but like
do you think that that was a very
pivotal moment in terms of just
reminding people like hey don't forget
I'm here like of course because there's
so many eyes anytime you get you know I
think it was the biggest versus like in
terms of viewership it was the biggest
one and
I mean anytime time you get that many
people in one space and you're able to
shine it's it's a big look for you and
it it shifts like people's awareness of
what you're up to you know even though
they know who you are it's just it's
just awareness thing
um but I think it's like
yeah it put me back in a mental space of
all right like it's like now it's time
to like really dive in and start getting
back to the music you know and then
since then it's just been you know
ongoing has your creative process
throughout the years changed in terms of
like when you're in the studio how
you're writing maybe the environment
you're in like how has it evolved like
to where you are now for example with
main one right are we outside it's I
don't even know what was it like a
Friday or Saturday night Me Andy Dre
London the whole gang it sounds like it
was there it was like Andy was there it
was a great time it was it was we
outside tiger was outside and then we
literally just go back to the studio
Mike's in the room whaps everywhere if
you listen to his second verse you go in
here like
it was just and normally when I record
I'm in a booth or sometimes I have it
out there because I Engineer myself but
like right when I'm working with people
I'm like I don't need my [__] to sound
it's spectacular so I'm you know I'm
gonna put my [__] in the booth but it
was just wondering and that those types
of moments show you like it don't have
to be perfect Perfection is is what you
focus on after you get the rose and you
didn't perfect it but like the actual
creative process does not have to be
perfect I feel like some something it's
just magic magic is Magic some artists
out think themselves for sure process
I've been there
and then we don't get the music right
and then it never comes out and then
that's different we still don't have the
detox that's that's that's that's funny
that's different though like I I
understand that it's like you wanna
when you talk about somebody like Dre
like that's like that's a lot of
pressure like you want to make sure
you're doing your best
your best work right and especially if
you're not releasing consistently it
gets harder and harder the longer you
wait to release the harder it gets to
pick that perfect record or that perfect
project and so I just been taking
chances lately and just having fun I
just feel like I'm having fun again like
that's the most important you probably
got into it man let's have fun exactly
now it's been it's been dope to see uh
for you we've been getting singles yeah
is there an album on the way it's
definitely out on the way okay I haven't
started it yet I mean I got over two
thousand three thousand records in the
hard drive but Jesus I don't feel like I
stutter on the album yeah like the Tupac
r b with your unreleased [__] man it's
crazy I was just my boy my DJ was
telling me he was like yo just send me
all your records and let me put together
an album like let me see what I was like
that could be fun actually that could be
fun that could be dope you know what I'm
saying but yeah I I haven't I haven't
started on the project yet so yeah so
there's only one more single after this
one and then
um no there's gonna be tour single
another single
tour one more single and then a project
like I'm just really sit down and work
on music so tell me about the tour
so the tour Neil hit me a couple months
ago you know he's like I'm doing this
tour he's one of my last major projects
I'm putting out and I'm on a tour I want
you to be on this campaigns and Roses
tour with me
I was like all right it's a short tour
it's short and sweet but it's fire me
him and and Robin Thicke I feel like we
all have overlapping audiences for sure
and um try to ride I just feel like it's
a lot of Classics records being sung on
that tour you know and it's a great Army
tour so and all you all you guys that
think are single right
um
no
it's actually the opposite I don't know
we outside though well I'm not trying to
like I don't know if Neo's business but
I know he got divorced recently and then
I think Robert hey man Leo's Neo man all
I'm saying is that those those listen
those backstage situations outside man
we outside and it's it's lit life is
good man I think like
I think when it comes to like being an
artist and and being in a relationship
I'm private with my [__] I just I don't
want people to see when I [__] up so
you're so private you're in a committed
I'm just telling you that I'm private in
my life because if I [__] up I don't
want nobody to know I respect that and
then you have to have well you also I'm
not about to put me on like a shade room
or whatever well you have to have that
um did you see um God Bless The Soul Man
shout out to little meech man he got
costumes which I won't [__] up did you
see black man don't cheat huh did you
see what happened with little meat man
he had to yeah you see the invisible
groceries I saw an invisible groceries
man I think that somebody what happened
was because this happened to me before
what happened was somebody you know I'm
saying photoshopped the groceries out of
his hand you're probably right you know
what I'm saying yeah he had Grocery and
like listen it's like man Define
groceries like maybe he had a candy bar
in his pocket that he was helping that
young lady obviously his cousin yeah I
love summer Walker man she's fighting
she's a legend she's she's fired I mean
she's a young goat you know he doing his
thing it's it's stuff out here I don't
know
yeah I watched it a few times
I haven't gotten into it yeah I don't
watch a lot of TV like that so fun I
ain't got enough time to watch TV like
you all right it's hard for me to like
sit and binge watch anything bro right
now I'm like so like in this mode of
like all right create yeah just like
just working I'm literally like on the
road all the time every weekend I'm out
of town if I'm not out of town I'm like
doing some other [__] to prepare for
something else like it's just you know I
don't really have time to watch TV uh
what's the last show you did binge watch
um the last show I did been watched was
you I like crazy [__] some crazy [__]
yeah I like I like Twisted dark [__]
that has something some beautiful like
silver lining in between it I just like
that because that's how my life have you
ever been you level obsessed with a
female in your life one thousand percent
wow every time well not I'm I'm an
obsessive type of dude I ain't gonna lie
like I like I obsess over what I love
Yeah unhealthy you're not like out here
murdering people nah I can't
um get away with it but if if like at
the end of the day I'm obsessive about
what I like for sure guaranteed yeah no
that's uh that's a wild show and then
you know it's crazy if you ever I don't
know if any of your female friends are
into uh these uh True True Detective
type shows like the [__] for like my
wife is into these murder mystery like
documentary shows that are on Hulu yeah
it's all that gets played in my house
and I've just be like it's always women
getting away with killing their husband
and I'm like
what are you what are we doing here are
you trying to apply something what the
[__] going on here you know what I'm
saying that's crazy
um so obviously you and Tyga recorded
this together yeah yeah we was we was in
a lab Wayne getting involved where's the
Wayne Uh do you send it out obviously
yeah so
um we were just discussing different uh
different features
and my bro AK was like yo
[__] what about Wayne and I was like yo
that's crazy I'm gonna text him because
I was like I just wanted it to feel like
I wanted somebody goaty on it you feel
me like me and tiger cool like I want
somebody if we do a third person it got
to be something like a goat yeah gotta
be a goat and then so I text Wayne I
said it to him and [__] he sent it back
like four or five days and it was up
from there that's a great turnaround
yeah I think was was it longer than that
it was like it's about four or five days
I don't think he like I think he he's
just so he impossible with this [__]
like you can he's just I don't even
think he write his lyrics now he just
goes he's one of them guys was this a
swapper did you have to pay Wayne how
does that work man you know this is his
business but it's also love involved you
feel me so he could use you on the
Carter 17 or whatever
I'd be down for sure we're waiting on
the Carter six let's go carter finals
shout out to Weezy man
um talk about your writing process
though are you riding down are you going
in are you doing the melody first
plugging in lyrics later this I I my
writing process is very race it depends
like if I'm under depression I'm working
with another artist I'm moving however
the energy moves like all right if we're
moving fast we right like we like with
this record we was just going back and
forth online it's back and forth back
and forth like older versions of the
record there's different we're singing
and he's rapping in different places
like it's it's a different but we're
just going back and forth
um with this record but usually I do my
Melodies first like I do I like to do my
melody all the way through it might have
some words here and there for like just
something some spitball [__] but most of
the time I do my Melodies first and then
I go back and then you're going to get
the lyrics oh I might just live with the
melody for a minute let it sit let it
sit down listen right and then let the
concept come I mean the melody is like
really like low-key the most important
part when it comes to a hit record like
you're not humming the lyrics You're
humming the melody you're definitely
humming the melody but well you say hit
you didn't say Thomas records so you're
right no like it's the difference
between a hit and a Timeless record like
I mean like lyrics are very important
but the Melody has to be there otherwise
for sure cannabis would be like the
biggest artist of all time because he's
a lyrical assassin you know what I'm
saying I'm not getting what you're
saying the melody is definitely
definitely important for sure but hit I
feel like hits is like you could have a
hit that don't have the greatest lyrics
but it's a hit for right now no it might
not be time we got some of those right
now I'm saying yeah we got some of those
what is this box what's going on here
it's just drugs in there weed oh it's
just weed I see something shout out to
king Tom so King Palm is uh our sponsor
and they have these giant Leafs and
there's weed inside oh this is an actual
blood yeah wow yeah it's sweet it's
crazy shout out to King Palm man make
sure you uh go get you some King Palm
also while we're doing this we might as
well shout out to Bluetooth
if you ever have any issues with your uh
situation you could use a Bluetooth man
I'm good I know but if you wanted to use
a blue chew yeah maybe you're dealing
with erectile dysfunction you use the
promo code you get a month for free you
know it's crazy maybe you're a little
drunk after the club a little little
whiskey dick it's happening to me at
least that happens to me in the past I
stopped drinking I I stopped drinking
four months ago but yeah it happens in
the past but it still work it still work
out but it works enough you just you
just gotta have it you know I'm saying
your [__] gotta be filming so that even
when it ain't all the way it's still
doing right well not everyone's blessed
like that you know but everyone's in at
the endowed like you sir no at the same
time it's like
it's like yo I promise you like I I
never
I don't think I ever tried anything to
make me last longer no [__] like that
you never had a gas station pill or a
honey pack nah bro don't [__] scare me
I'm like what if you take one of them
shits and your [__] is [__] up for
life I've never had one either just like
it just looked colorful and they just
look like some shoes I got this friend
though his name's uh silvon Marshall and
uh he always has uh these Blue Rhino
pills everywhere are we seeing them
shits yeah he also kind of looks like a
Blue Rhino oh he's right there that's so
fun yeah crazy huh
crazy no I was gonna ask you um what
made you stop drinking
um
[__] just knowing this room is about to
go on and I was going out all the time
and you know what I'm saying so like I
look at it like I have to sacrifice I
can't do everything
you know what I'm saying it's hard to
say no too because you're doing clubs
yeah you know what I'm saying because I
have to preserve myself so I mean I know
the run I'm not trying to go on I know
like the ghosts are like I just like you
know what I'm gonna cut this out I got
my other little
tricks that I do but like the drinking
part I could have no more no more
alcohol and then also it's like
obviously I lost a lot of calories it's
like unneeded bruh I feel like [__] the
next day and you're about to go on the
road you want to be a [__] straight
chisel up bro yeah I mean for the road
I'm definitely about to get right but I
just like I feel like [__] the next day
it's crazy I don't know some people can
go crazy like that and be like [__] I'm
we up at nine o'clock tell me about your
relationship with psychedelics
man I have a long-standing relationship
with plant medicine I don't like to
disrespecting my calling them
psychedelics okay because some people
take that role I call it plant medicine
plant medicine um I just respect I feel
like there's so many different healing
um
properties in plant medicine are you
talking about shrooms you talk about
peyote I uh DMC all that I definitely
think it's not something you take every
day you know what I'm saying shrooms you
can but sometimes yeah you can micro
dose every day right be productive the
other ones is like yeah you're not going
to do DMT every day if you want to sit
with yourself and you want to kind of
see yourself in in super present moment
outside of time and space like for me I
think taking plant medicine
reminds you where you who you are beyond
the physical right and and it's there it
could also be therapy it's it's deep
therapy deep therapy with yourself that
nobody else can help you with you just
have to be ready to face yourself
um honestly speaking I wish that my
mother would have taken
Ayahuasca or some of these plant
medicine it would have helped her with
her addiction I'm sure one thousand
percent I feel the same way about people
think if I would have known that I would
have that's something I definitely would
have if there's people in my life who
like I was growing up with like my
family members and I'm like damn like if
I had a you know I got family members
I've overdosed yeah and been through all
that [__] too so it's like damn like I
just think right now even if you don't
take plant medicine right now is the
time to just expand your horizons as a
being you know we are faced we're in a
spiritual war right now so it's time to
like really tap in with yourself on a
whole other level because life ain't
gonna get easier if you don't start to
understand who you are well they just uh
decriminalized it in Oakland San
Francisco
obviously Oregon Washington Canada but I
think the whole state of California is
coming soon
Therapeutics the therapeutic purposes
because people who have PTSD have been
in the military yep
um shout out to all the veterans man
they could really get some of my homes
is better there's even like MDMA therapy
you know so there's definitely a lot
like I have a friend of mine who was
probably the biggest degenerate I top
five I've ever met in my life
um and this dude did he went to Malibu
and he did two days of Ayahuasca wow and
it was like it was almost like a he said
it was like 30 years of therapy yeah man
wrapped up in a two days because so what
happens is that we hold so much trauma
in our in our tissue and our bones and
where because we're vibrational beings
these things sit there and they don't
leave until we work them out and they're
suppressed you don't even you might even
know they're there even though they're
there yeah right and so
um when you do these plant medicines
what happens is it goes in and literally
vibrationally breaks things up and opens
you up opens your pineal gland opens you
up so you can see and feel everything
that's why some people think they have
trips that are like not as good because
they're purging all of this [__] yeah
right that they've been holding on for
years and years and even past life
traumas and all this type of [__] so
it's really it's not a joke you know
what I'm saying it's not it's not people
think it's like a party thing and it's
like no this is like some real medicine
for real like it's a medicine for real
exactly exactly like I think of like uh
I just expecting all [__] going on and
all these people overdose I'm like man
if they would just legalize some of this
[__] it would like change a lot of
people's lives because I think biggest
thing with addiction is like the
withdrawals getting people off shaking
people like disconnected from right
people want to say ability people want
want that that numbness some people want
the numbness some people just wanna
do it for Creative purposes some people
are addicts to it some people I just
think people like to sometimes have some
type of escape and you can micro dose
before you work out
it gives you a little I never did that
before I got homies who are jacked and
they will do a micro doses their
pre-workout which is you know I'm like
hey that's it good for you I'm not doing
that but yeah no
um how are you feeling about all the new
alien news that's been coming out
alien did you see that we got to stop
the interview real quick to tell you
about our folks at my bookie man look my
bookie NFL season is approaching and you
know what they just added that I love is
that early cash out let's say you got a
ticket and it's looking great you can
cash out early on that ticket all right
I love it all right plus of course my
bookie's got the full casino going down
and if you sign up right now using the
promo code bootleg they will give you
that first deposit bonus up to a
thousand dollars all right so head over
to my bookie ASAP um look we got a NFL
coming there's baseball you can gamble
on right now and of course the full
service casino blackjack with the real
dealer uh roulette craps whatever you're
into slot machines you could do it and
cash out right on my bookie all right
all you got to do is sign up with that
new promo code bootleg when you sign up
trust me when I say it's a new account
they're gonna get you that uh first
deposit bonus all right so go to uh my
bookie right now use that promo code
bootleg when you sign up for a new
account also got to give a big shout out
to the family at kingpom
um the official sponsor of the bootleg
cab podcast what I love about King Palm
is of course it's all about organic all
right no tobacco this is straight
organic um leaves it's the only thing I
smoke out of and what I love about it is
they have these terpene infused flavor
tips and they are so good the squeezing
pops this is the watermelon
um man they got the dragon fruit they
got the grape whatever you're into trust
me they got it all right they're
available at your local smoke shop
um you can also go to kingpom.com and
use the promo code bootleg and save half
off so 50 off if you use that promo code
bootleg at kingpom.com and uh man trust
me the squeeze and pop is where it's at
I've had so many people come in here and
they're like yo you squeeze and then you
get the flavor right away all right it's
and of course it's tobacco-free it's a
healthy smoke so make sure you rock with
King Palm at your local 7-Eleven your
local liquor store or go get 50 off at
kingpong.com promo code bootleg
let's get back to the interview
well the guy I mean it's been aliens I
mean we it's just old news to me in my
opinion I mean I agree too listen I'm
like I'm inside of it nobody else I feel
like I'm watching a cartoon
I feel like they're preparing us for
something a little bit though but the
Hebrew word for Elion is is is a being
of light is is it even involved being
you know so it's like we are aliens like
you know what I'm saying it's like if
you if you understand what's happening
if you really study I mean all of this
to make people just want to study
everything study everything you can so
that you'll see that this movie that
they're trying to play for you is not
real and that [__] is all [__] and
it's just I don't know it's just so
obvious we are the aliens we here what
do you think is your calling Mario
outside of music I'm talking 20 30 years
from now if if we could remember you I'm
not saying I don't believe in other
entities that have been here and are
here and other off Planet but I don't
believe how they're trying to depict
they actually downgrading what's
actually happening what's you know what
I'm saying they're giving us the diet
version yeah it's like yeah they're
giving us the sugar for you want to tap
into off-planet energies you can do that
yourself you don't need the government
to do it just get to my washers have you
done DMT yes yeah was it fun
it's it's
um 15 minutes right yeah like eight
miles less than eight to ten minutes I
was having sex while I was doing it I
ain't gonna lie I was like fully awake
like I'm I'm bro I
sex on DMT yes what's that like
super like you're you don't really feel
the physical act of it but because it's
your your body's not really you don't
feel your body right you feel everything
you lit everything is just
there's no separation wow from what I
experienced and um yeah but I was still
very much so in my body and very much so
in my light body so it's just like yeah
I've I've yes it was interesting I've
yet to do DMT I'm a little I haven't
done it in a while I'm a little
intimidated because uh I have a friend
who does it and he'll do it once or
twice a year and he freebases it so he
does it like or he does it I've been
there when he did it and I got sketched
I was like I'm good I think that when
you take plant medicine
depending on where you are spiritually
where you are awareness wise and
consciously is going to affect you
different every time yeah so he like was
gone for like about 15 minutes and came
back and was like
what he remembered because he's like
there's just too much [__] coming in for
me to like really remember everything
but he was like it felt like I was gone
for like six months since it was like
going to work and living a life like in
15 minutes I was like this is crazy like
I don't want to be somewhere for six
months yeah I mean anytime now that I do
anything I always set intentions now but
I do I think intention is important yeah
because if even if you're going if
you're doing if you're doing psilocybin
your intention is important because you
could be if you're at the club and
you're drinking and you're like let's do
some shrooms while I'm drinking whiskey
shots and together shots every time it's
chemistry every time you're doing
different things you're adding a
different vibrational uh response to it
yeah you're changing the state of it by
mixing it with something else so you're
gonna have a different reaction it's
just like when you walk in certain rooms
your energy can shift the room based
upon your because everybody has a
magnetic field 360 Degrees around them
and whatever's in that field it could be
the person you was with last night it
could be your it's so much [__] going on
you gotta be selectively around you man
or or maybe you want that energy and you
want to use that energy you just I just
think you just have to be aware whatever
you're calling about whatever you want
to happen good or bad whatever it's your
world do do as you will but you know
just know speaking of the question I was
asking you what do you think your
calling is that's outside of Music am I
calling like just you know if we're
talking about I mean
I think is to connect with like-minded
individuals who
um know who they are and has a sense of
awareness above
whatever is being
you know presented to them so that you
can create solutions for Humanity we can
create solutions for Humanity that may
not be
um easy to do I think that there's
definitely a caller for All Soul
families right now like your soul family
could be people that you meet or run
into that y'all just feel like this
connection with each other that's like
protective or like yo like I just trust
this person like we we have same ideals
in life we may be in different fields I
got friends who are in completely
different fields of music that I connect
with that are just you know incredibly
powerful people and have
um
special gifts you know I'm saying of
healing or they may be great at you know
um
uh connecting uh connecting a dots when
it comes to
solutions for neighborhoods or or inner
cities like certain it just it's just so
much
and so I think right now the soul
families are connecting you know what
I'm saying outside of us getting money
and hustling like whatever it is your
superpowers are there's there's
people out there that's supposed to be
on your team to do whatever needs to be
done when the time is I think over the
next few years we're going to see a lot
of shifts in Consciousness right and
because right now
the
everything is splitting like so
realities are completely splitting
towards though you can be living your
chosen reality and another person could
be living there chosen reality and they
will not overlap and y'all can be in the
same space facts you feel me and so when
you understand that you really can live
the life you want to live and not worry
about being affected by other [__]
because it's not real I think too like
your story is very relatable to what a
lot of young men and kids are going
through in today's world because
addiction levels and having parents that
you know my son would do that you know
my son's mom was [__]
dope fiend out for sure like I'm sorry
to hear that [__] yeah
um but I feel like you have a story that
like a lot of people can like pull like
real inspiration from like that hey like
you know [__] could be bad but like that
doesn't mean that like you know
you still can't get to it like you can
you gotta overcome you can overcome your
surroundings you can overcome your
trauma you can overcome your heart
you're meant to overcome it yeah you
know what I'm saying like you meant to
overcome everything that you you see or
witness as a struggle or something
that's trying to hold you down I don't
think anything is trying to hold us down
that is in the Unseen realm is the
things that are in the same realm quote
unquote that's actually trying to hold
you down okay and and make you think a
certain way
because everything that you can't see is
actually working for you that's real you
know what I'm saying it's really the
[__] that you can you got you know what
I'm saying you got allies that you can't
see and I think that that when you think
like that and you feel like that you
believe that you're gonna get that
support you know what I'm saying and I
feel like I've I've always believed that
even growing up I always believed that I
was born with that in me so that's why I
feel like I've been able to sustain
without family without you know certain
people that were protected I always felt
protected I still do people feel like I
got an army around me at all times I
just I feel it I know it's there
um for you uh I gotta ask which version
because you obviously have one of the
biggest records of all time are we do we
like the remix to let me love you or the
yo G which one are you taking I mean
I like the OG I like them both
you know what I'm saying I'm an OG guy
but I mean listen Jadakiss on the reader
it was T.I Jada
it is classic
was having on all the r b remixes and
[__] the Barry James he was still he one
of the coldest man he wanted a coldest
100 do this [__] but yeah I might like
the OG do you feel like um because there
was like this big discussion which I
didn't think was necessarily fair when I
understood what did he was doing because
I think Diddy is an r b head and
indeedy's also working on r b albums so
I understand why he said I want to be
was dead but I mean obviously I don't
agree with him I don't even think he
might all the way agree with himself on
that but do you feel like R B's finally
kind of because now when I listen to the
radio
or I play songs on the radio listen yeah
right but like you know I think of a
song last year like money Long's record
is like a that's a real r b record that
like went top 40 that went like Rhythm
like that to me like is like a sign of
like okay like r b is kind of coming
back in terms of like it being more
popular music not to say it's ever gone
anywhere you mean that yeah the actual
popularity of it there's so many
different
styles of r b there is there's like sub
genres of r b sub genres and I don't
think it's ever really died I think like
you said it's just what's what became
popular it's like I mean yeah it's so
cool too right the the the playlists and
the radios were more condensed yeah so
you had everything kind of playing in
the same spaces you know what I'm saying
but then as as the digital Crusade
happened earlier when you start to
compartmentalize things now you put this
in this compartment it makes it easier
to for one genre to stand in front right
so but also there's a lot more hip-hop
being you know what I'm saying pushed
but I think a lot of the conversation
about r b being dead was just to create
dialogue I think that's what it was I
think that's like I think that's really
what Jesus was doing and it worked and
I'm happy he did that you know what I'm
saying he's a pioneer he's a goat in
this [__] so who better to do it we got
to stop the interview real quick to tell
you about our folks at my bookie man
look my bookie NFL season is approaching
and you know what they just added that I
love is that early cash out let's say
you got a ticket and it's looking great
you can cash out early on that ticket
all right I love it all right plus of
course my bookie's got the full casino
going down and if you sign up right now
using the promo code bootleg they will
give you that first deposit bonus up to
a thousand dollars all right so head
over to my bookie ASAP um look we're at
uh NFL coming there's baseball you can
gamble on right now and of course the
full service casino blackjack with the
real dealer uh roulette craps whatever
you're into slot machines you could do
it and cash out right on my bookie all
right all you got to do is sign up with
that new promo code bootleg when you
sign up
trust me when I say it's a new account
they're gonna get you that uh first
deposit bonus all right so go to uh my
bookie right now use that promo code
bootleg when you sign up for a new
account also got to give a big shout out
to the family at kingpong
um the official sponsor of the bootleg
kit podcast what I love about King Palm
is of course it's all about organic all
right no tobacco this is straight
organic um leaves it's the only thing I
smoke out of and what I love about it is
they have these terpene infused flavor
tips and they are so good the squeezing
pops this is the watermelon
um man they got the dragon fruit they
got the grape whatever you're into trust
me they got it all right they're
available at your local smoke shop
um you can also go to kingpom.com and
use the promo code bootleg and save half
off so 50 off if you use that promo code
bootleg kingpom.com and uh man trust me
the squeeze and pop is where it's at
I've had so many people come in here and
they're like yo you squeeze and then you
get the flavor right away all right it's
and of course it's tobacco-free it's a
healthy smoke so make sure you rock with
King Palm at your local 7-Eleven your
local liquor store or go get 50 off at
kingpong.com promo code bootleg
let's get back to the interview if you
had to make an r b super group with two
other singers who would you put in your
super group one album your t t what was
it TGT
how many months how many genuine dude
two more three three you gotta pick two
other guys to be in a super group crazy
um
bro that's crazy like I'm mad to say
usher and CB oh
[Music]
I mean yeah that's those are the two
right answers when you say r b and then
like Generations like I feel like
that's like Usher's gonna grab a little
bit older than me yeah CB's gonna grab
mine and younger and then I'm like in
the middle grabbing it you know what I'm
saying but this detection the voice text
phone in the jail verse from R Kelly
yeah Hey listen I ain't gonna lie to you
I bump his [__] every [__] day me too
every [__] day
listen I am not ashamed to say I can
separate the art from the art it comes
to an artist who has been able to make
every type of song and have every type
of have fun a baby man come on man I
believe I can fly to half on a baby to
you know
he's just the goat he's the guy but you
know listen it's him a rusher because I
went to Usher show in Vegas have you
seen his Vegas show of course I'm just
talking about but you can't compare them
to bro
you can't compare Usher and R Kelly in
terms of being the ghost of R B Because
all right Kelly his pin
I agree I think R Kelly's got the
greatest pen ever probably he wrote for
Michael Jackson like
baby making songs pop records like I'm a
big wreck like but you know what you
know what R Kelly never got though I
don't know
he never got like a OMG he didn't really
participate in that but he can't come
out in that time no but I was gonna
because but think about it right well
listen I mean Usher came out in 94. no
but but
R Kelly was not he was not incarcerated
in 2010 when every R B artist was doing
shitty EDM songs do you remember that
era right absolutely that don't count
that's cheat code [__] I don't think it
counts like when Neo and Pit Bull were
playing I can't worldly you can't have
the Army conversation at that point
that's out so listen I agree with you
for this I think R Kelly's the greatest
of all time
I think when you factor in everything
okay
I give Usher all his life I think it's
got to be Usher he gave me my flowers at
the show shows I just think Usher is
like a like amazing not only is he got
the classics but he also the
entertainment because I've seen R Kelly
live when I was a little kid I saw him
in Nas and it was great that's different
I don't know I think but it was like
categorize it I feel like R Kelly was
more like he was like more like when you
watched him live it was like kind of
like watching a rapper he had background
dances right as a performer no we're not
sure on [__] skates bro Christmas out
here a superstar he's a performer he's
like a he's a pop r b he's an r b
Superstar what are we talking about just
R B music I have to Crown R Kelly I have
to I respect that and and I agree
and there's a lot I mean there's so many
great artists man I think it's quite
different I think the three names that I
I mean and this is just speaking of
somebody who was born in 1987 but then
you got a crowd CB2 listen I was gonna
say the three Chris Brown ushering R
Kelly yeah you got a crowd CB man like
he he's an alioma I think he's the most
alien talented artist he him ever I
think it's him and it's Jamie Foxx
because I'm just thinking Talent I'm not
talking about music I just mean
Talent inside of a human being yeah for
sure Chris Brown can paint a mural on a
building
he can dance maybe all-time great dancer
him and Michael Jackson he could sing he
could write he could wrap his ass off he
could act ish oh you know it was all
right uh and then he could hoop he could
I mean I mean listen then there's Jamie
Foxx who can do all that and he's one of
the greatest stand-up comedians of all
time yeah man he's one of the greatest
actors ever like it's a lot of it's a
lot of Challenge and in our culture bro
it's a lot of talent it's crazy would
you uh would you ever do a uh Vegas
residential residency show one day
um yes I definitely would for sure
because
I just feel like there's so many pockets
that I can go into you know I've done
Broadway I've done acting I've toured I
mean when it comes to doing residencies
you really have time to put together a
show and perfect it yeah like a real
entertainment show like and when it
comes to that like I I love that space
so I definitely would and I would
incorporate all of my talents in one
show for sure
um can you tell me uh how how nervous
were you the first time back in the day
because I was just talking to my boy and
we were trying to go over we were
talking about how Roxy and big TIG are
very slept on in terms of when we talk
about the the best host of photosystem
park because everyone says Adrian free
and I'm like Roxy and Tig did their
thing too but how nervous were you the
very first time going on 106 and Park
like were you nervous like what was that
day like pulling up to 106 and Park bro
I think it's more anxious because it's
your peers you know what I'm saying it's
like 106 in part I felt like I was going
back to high school and seeing all my
peers like you go in the audience they
got people your age yes kid it was like
like Teenage [__] in the crowd it's like
you it feels like a party like you know
what I'm saying so I wasn't nervous it
was just more anxious to like and
exciting and [__] because this is like I
don't even know if they have they don't
even have shows like that anymore like I
just watched a random performance pop up
on my story of like that [__] was fun
man it was when you when you went to 106
it was like a reunion it was like an
event yeah I saw do you remember when
genuine performed and they had to reset
him and it was like
a little bigger than this table right
here crazy man it's classic so main one
is out it's going crazy it's featuring
Tyga it's uh it's featuring Lil Wayne
um are you gonna have any uh sort of uh
obviously like you got 3 000 unreleased
songs so that's you know it's crazy
Jesus uh you already have the next
single pick though nah nah nah I don't
have any pick I like to stay fresh bro
like I'm going in the lab and cooking
for that would you like for these next
few shows I'm probably lacking in it
just would you ever uh reunite with the
uh Scott Storage here for sure yeah I
talked to Scott two weeks ago we got
records that could possibly be something
you know what I'm saying already but we
definitely tap them back in for sure
I'll just talk to a lot of cigarette
smoke in that session bro Scott yo Scots
he'll smoke down them cigs and then he's
a he's you know what's crazy well he in
the studio with me he don't really he
don't really smoke he'll go outside the
studio no no he'll smoke outside
cigarettes like that I see him smoking
weed I'm smoking and he'll smoke
cigarettes I don't see him smoke
cigarettes George is a sweetheart man
he's a great guy I can't wait for the to
make
the movie about his life crazy because
it's gonna be in [__] saying I don't
even want it to be a movie I want it to
be like a HBO Max original it's so many
legendary I want 50 Cent to be the
executive producer like the sky storage
store that could be fire because he had
sex with everybody first everybody like
Ray J did not hit it first time Scott
Storage right anyway
um all right so look the single is going
crazy is there gonna be uh anything uh
visual wise coming with it video just
came out video just dropped us out right
now
so yeah we're going up um and then
obviously I'm on the way what made you
get back with the major because you're
obviously back you're you're with epic
which you know you've in a different
capacity you know it's more like a
partnership and really just you know
Sylvia Zeke you know what I'm saying
we've been talking about you know
working for a minute
and uh my business partner Andy AKA 365
management like we we decided to
collectively go that route because you
know we just been put I just put a lot
of work in on the ground you know what
I'm saying and just like learning the
the business aspect of this [__] for
like the last seven years yeah in the
independent space right and um yeah I
just felt like it was time to to have an
addition to the team I love it I like
the I like the house over there I like
who's there yeah you know what I'm
saying except for
yeah I'm excited for you man but look
the singles out go crazy go support it
and then uh make sure you get tickets to
go watch you neo and Robin Thicke yes
sir on tour that's gonna be a fun
concert should be a lot of ladies in
there it has been every show yeah every
[__] show go run that up uh
appreciate you pulling up brother always
mate yeah congrats on your and
everything you're doing too man Mario
hustle boom
hey what up man uh you just watched
another episode of the bootleg cat
podcast brought to you by hard Dean baby
shout out to the family at hardean don't
forget
make sure if you're in Las Vegas you get
into that taxi as soon as you land you
get into that Uber say take me to
hardine all right they're gonna take get
you taken care of the most craziest
Premium Selection of cannabis you'll
ever find Under One Roof it's a vibe in
there the bud tenders they're gonna take
care of you man listen tell them I sent
you they're gonna get you right shout
out to the family at hardine in Las
Vegas the number one dispensary in the
world all right and we are so proud to
be partners with them so shout out to
hardeen go follow them online Harding
underscore Las Vegas and check out their
website hardinglasvegas.com get you some
swag you know you can't buy this but you
know yeah shout out to hardine